my name is Alexy and with Google Play
business development for application in
Central and Eastern Europe and I'm
Ricardo engineering lay down and Revital
and we are going to talk with you about
application quality in Android
application quality in the Android
ecosystem has always been a top priority
for us and we have been moving away from
just installations and user rights in
Play application rankings and start
focusing on more complex and exact
metrics like engagement and about
performance today we are going to talk
about this all in detail first of all
away it's important to have a quality
app then how can you troubleshoot your
technical issues and master Android
writers and help you can build an
excellent product on this great
technical foundation first of all why
quality matters why it's important
a quality directly impact the success of
your business on Google Play we have run
an analysis on our top apps and games in
Google Play rankings a quality score and
we have seen some spectacular results
for example one application moved from
average to good quality we can see up to
seven times uplift in retention and
sixth time uplift in spending those
applications our partners support of
those findings for example the london
europe speaking fashioned platform they
focused on a reliability in performance
and emanating bugs and making their
application faster and this has not only
increased the organic traffic that
getting as they provided the positive
impact on as their revenue growing the
LTV lifetime value per user how much
stability matters the answer is in
matters a lot again our findings found
out that if you pay if the application
crashes a lot and a lot means to more
than 5% crashes they have a 30% more
uninstallation in the first day then
modest they perhaps you have seen this
previously but again I want to remind
you that
application performance and quality is
the main driver of a user white or
anything's with 50% of negative reviews
mention stability and crush and 60% of
positively used mentioning speed design
reliability you know what to focus on to
make your app excellent another again
our partners support those findings and
busu a language learning app they saw
significant growth in the average
ranking when they increase the
performance of applications and
everybody knows how difficult it is to
grow the application from already high
ranking 44.1 lastly in addition to those
objective fractions and your business
growth there are some rewards you can
get from Google Play from having
equality applications those benefits as
a boost of organic traffic featuring and
some occasional awards you can get from
us for example if the application cache
sought it gets a lot of negative reviews
and bad user ratings it can decrease
your application from at ability Google
Play and when we are speaking
application for featuring we have
already paid a lot of attention to its
overall quality and platform support now
we are starting to look at your Android
white us to see if the app actually
performs and work stable and at the end
of the day you can get a lot of specific
Google Awards with some time runs some
kind of best application of the year or
material design award which can do
wonders for your PR and promote your
application
one of such a word is Android excellence
which we have announced on Google i/o
and which we have updated two times
already
it's a quarterly collection of best
content based apps and games the Android
ecosystem has to offer and this is some
top and great applications you can all
look for inspiration and some great
ideas on how to build Android
applications now our to the technical
excellence thank you so you heard from
Kobe in the keynote about Android vitals
I want to spend ten minutes walking you
through how I can help you
what is on Revital hundred vitals is a
program that Google created to help you
create apps and games of exemplary
quality we launched it at Google i/o
with Android vitals dashboards in the
play console in there you can see
aggregated performance information about
your app data is collected automatically
no action required from you from
millions of devices worldwide from any
user that has agreed to share data with
Google for example when they have bought
unbox the new device
thanks to these everyone in your
companies from engineers all the way to
the CEO can understand app quality and
set KPIs around it
how does android vitals work is a
combination of three things metrics
tools and rewards metrics I mean bad
behaviors these are application
practices and patterns and events that
are detrimental to the user experience
like crashes and battery drains all the
things that you want to avoid tools
imply Council to help you understand and
improve your app quality from before
release with the pre-launch report at
release time with risk dashboard and
after release when your app is live with
the Android vitals dashboard and finally
rewards as alexei mentioned rewards in
search and discovery for apps that show
exemplary behavior what I mean by bad
behaviors if you got one read vitals
today so far you will see that we
explained performance across three key
domains stability battery and rendering
for stability we tell you whenever your
application is crashing or freezing
application not responding for battery
we already inform you when your
application is closing unnecessary
battery drains for example by keeping
the CPU on excessively or for too long
amount of time or waking the device up
too often and for rendering we highlight
whenever the applications is slow lower
than 60 frames per second or stuttering
with frozen frames
we've seen massive momentum since we
launched the Google i/o over 65% of
playtop apps are engaging with android
vitals regularly over 60,000 app
developers worldwide and by working
closely with over 50 partners some of
you in the audience as well we observe
that they were able on average to reduce
their crush rate from 3.5% down to 1.7
which is massive and this means that
since Google i/o over 1.5 billion
installations were delivered to users
leading them to apps that are better and
less crushing thanks to these many for
many partners Android vitals is now an
active part of their planning and they
observe a direct impact on customer
satisfaction by focusing on app quality
like the Weather Channel here
so inspired by all of this I want to
announce three new things today expand
the device coverage five additional new
metrics to help you understand and act
on up quality and a completely new user
experience in the Play console first
expanded device coverage until now
Android vitals only reported performance
pertaining to Nexus and pixel devices in
the last three months we work with
several OMS to surface performance
metrics for many new devices across the
spectrum from high-end flagship devices
to mid-range bestsellers to low-end
devices and this means that we are able
to cover over 50 times more amount of
sessions tracked by the program
so if until now you were not able to get
sufficient representative information in
Android vitals I encourage you to go and
check it today because it's going to be
much better we increased the set of
metrics that we report starting with
additional metrics around stability and
battery for stability
obviously repeating crashes are induced
user frustration because the apps
appears irremediably broken and this
leads to higher knees loss so now you
can see additional new metrics around
multi ANR's percentage of sessions
during
which users experience more than one
freeze during a session and the same for
crushes on battery we focused on
excessive background activity excessive
background activity consumes a necessary
battery when the user is away from the
phone and Europe will not receive much
usage if the phone is dead when the user
comes back to it and so we have three
new metrics there one is excessive Wi-Fi
scans in the background whenever the
apps perform too many Wi-Fi scans when
not in active use same is for excessive
network usage you wouldn't be able to
see whenever your application is
consuming an excessive amount of data
and network usage while the app is not
in active use and stuck by ground
wakelocks the percentage of sessions
when the app was keeping the CPU on for
more than one hour while it was in the
background not in active use to help you
with all of this we also significantly
revamp the play console user experience
to help you understand improve Europe
quality more in easier ways there is a
new overview page that gives that helps
you understand your overall app quality
at a glance across all performance
metrics it is life now you can check it
out as soon as you're out of this
session there is a new straight at the
top of the page and highlight section
that points out any bad behaviors that
are triggering for your app right now so
you can immediately focus on the most
important actions you can now track the
performance of your app over time and
see whenever you improve or you regress
on your application quality and observe
the impact of the actions that you took
to improve to facilitate reducing for
any bad behaviors that might trigger you
can now slice the data by any
combination of version code devices OS
version time to really dive into what
are the main problems that may be
affecting your app and to help you
understand the opportunities in further
you have now benchmarks that help you
establish reference points how your
behavior fares against the top 10,000
apps
and we highlight what is the performance
of the bottom quartile so you can see
what the opportunity for improvement is
for your app to capture compared to
peers and finally we want to help you
take action and be guided into recovery
whenever there is a problem so for
example in the case of application
freezes which have some time hard to
debug because multiple causes contribute
to them we now highlight what caused led
to them across many different reasons
from deadlocks to excessive disk i/o to
excessive network i/o excessive database
usage suspended threads due to garbage
collection and much more straight from
the play console all UI so thanks to
these partners are using vitals more and
more to continue investing in app
quality and is great to see feedback
like these from big-fish games around
specific features like the effectiveness
of benchmarks I want to cover one more
thing around pre launch report pre
launch report is place solution for
automated app testing before production
releases it automatically CROs apks on
10 physical devices looking for crashes
and security vulnerabilities and what we
observe is that in ninety percent of the
time whenever pre-launch report
discovers a crash the app was then not
pushed the production so very effective
in preventing bad experiences reaching
your users three big news for this today
first no more need to opt-in into the
service this was the case until now
every apk that is going to be now from
today submitted to alpha or the beta
track will automatically be tested by a
pre-launch report so for many of you you
will now start seeing the result without
any opt-in to do we completely rewrote
and improved the automated crawler that
navigates Europe to understand better
the content of Europe and reach deeper
into that with increased coverage and me
more effective at detecting crashes that
would have otherwise reached users in
production and the last one we launched
an entire new section centered on
performance metrics that are collected
during the troll so as the robot
explores your app you will now then be
able to replay what the crawler did and
next to the video of what the crawler
you will see performance metric around
CPU memory Network and rendering so you
can understand if specific actions in
your app are particularly troublesome
all of these I hope will help you
leading you to unhealthy app but then
how do you make it memorable and how do
you make it
excellent and for this I will leap back
to illumine okay
so Android fighters hopefully they
helped you to build a great application
from the technical perspective it works
stable it works fast
smooth and there is no issues how no I
do go up from that and how do we build a
master an excellent product what's the
next step the next step is building
useful products from our useful features
are the users twelve from using
beautiful design and using all Android
platform can offer you let's talk about
this in a little bit more detail first
of all material design the concept got a
lot of praise from independent
developers and independent designers
there are a lot of material about how
can you implement an adult of a material
design in your applications both from
Google and from our partners
remember that just reusing some pre-made
companies we have a plenty of them does
not make application material you should
sync material and use any application
from the ground up or keeping the main
concept in mind and having you up in
material design definitely helps you
engagement because users on Android are
they used to other common approaches and
common elements of material design next
step is a platform support equality app
is an up-to-date application we
encourage you to use the latest SDK and
and support the latest version of
Android operating system and as soon as
there is a new developer preview of the
next version or as soon as there's a
better version next Android build try
and test your application again against
it to be ready for its release of course
there are a lot of different platforms
we actually built on Android and
supporting them you improve the
application quality and there are some
cross-platform tools for example like
sign-in with Google and smart dock which
help your users to create accounts all
log in seamlessly speaking about the
relevant platforms there are plenty of
devices running Android out there
wearables tables a Smart TVs we are
devices and connected cars not
everything is relevant for each your
applications user case but when is
relevant in definitely help boost your
application our quality and benefit from
supporting of those platforms
monetization with Google Play billing is
another great example of how your
application can increase the quality if
the users love you up so much so ready
to pay for your content and for your
services it's definitely a sign of a
quality application as a premium content
in-app purchases or subscriptions after
it goes through a certain threshold we
will consider your application as a more
quality app of course there is also
Android Play which is launched in many
regions across Germany not Germany of
course but for example in Poland in
Russia
Android pay is up and running and our
party reporters they can get up to 20
percent more paying users for our
services with Android Play so supported
and in
additional revenue and additional users
moving on from the application itself to
the play distinct this is the most
important thing for your anger I have
any traffic and conversions to install
there a lot of play listing tools which
of course most of you already knew and
use which include promo videos a be
testing and better an alpha channel
which help you or deliver quality
application to your users you can also
use the play console to respond to users
reviews in the native tongue a pin
helping resolve the issues and boost the
application rating keeping it about for
when your rating is about four points it
generally the main threshold we need to
put you up in some kind of promise
featuring in other activities and of
course all of those experiments with
playlist in help with your conversion
and our partners definitely support
those findings so if you experiment with
your screenshot with your description
and other parts of your listing it can
boost your conversion for example well
up here they increase the conversion by
17% by testing short descriptions which
append a distinction orders for the best
results of such testing you definitely
should have a clear hypothesis and some
big design variations because only those
activities called
get variable great results so to sum
everything up so to sum everything up
first of all the application quality
directly affects your business success
and customer satisfaction and then as I
mentioned with andrey vitals you can
understand and troubleshoot your
technical issues to lead to an excellent
app from expanded device coverage new
metrics new console experience an
entirely revamped performance action in
pre-launch report and a better crawler
and platform and optional product
excellence help you get more traffic and
become more visible on Google Play
getting more users and helping your
business grow
you